- Hey, college boy, why don’t you make like you did at USC
and leave before you get started?
- Good one, Sean!
- Thanks...Bengals coach.
- It’s Zac Taylor.
- OSCAR ISAAC! DAISY RIDLEY!
- AIR RAID! AIR RAID!
- The Kliffdalorian, is it true you had a losing record in college?
- You’re hired! Here's a gift basket I made you.
- He’s so…small.
- We have to cut him.
- Now let's go ruin the Eagles.
- NO, NOT MIAMI! JUST KILL ME!
- For your next bounty, we want close losses to good teams!
- I WILL DESTROY THAT CHILD.
- HEY, HOW DO YOU MAKE YOURS DO COOL THINGS?
- WHO WANTS A BABY?  I’M DAN SNYDER, AND I’M ABANDONING BABIES NOW.
- It’s me, Zac Taylor,
coach of the CINCINNATI BENGALS and
Gridiron Heights’ hot new breakout character.
Please subscribe below so every episode
can have more ZAC TAYLOR!
We’re gonna have Zac Taylor T-shirts, Zac Taylor plushies,
Zac Taylor video games.
ZAC ATTACK, Y’ALL!